no that's not kim kardashian out on the
town with her estranged husband kanye
west that's the rapper with a kim
lookalike that i don't know it all went
down on monday night when the 44 year
old musician was photographed at nobu in
malibu with cheney jones yeah that's not
kim people
but cheney she looks a whole lot like
her
rocking long black wavy hair blue shades
a black bodysuit and lace up thigh high
heeled boots
very kim k
yep honestly cheney's whole instagram
account could be a kim doppelganger page
it's a different experience for sure so
who is cheney well according to her
instagram she's a model and a college
graduate who opened a mental health
practice in atlanta last year who had
better grades in school
straight a student right here double
degree 4.0
now it's unclear if cheney and kanye
were on a date but we do know he's been
dating actress julia fox who was spotted
out in new york city on monday wearing a
yeezy jacket and the hermes birken bag
kanye gifted her for her birthday it was
really surreal i mean it was just fun
just something from my heart as for
kanye he rocked this all black look for
his night out showing off his muscular
biceps in a tank top and jeans that he
paired with some tall boots
and while kanye and kim are currently at
odds publicly feuding on social media it
hasn't stopped the rapper from
interacting with kim's friends and
family in fact kim's sister kylie
jenner's boyfriend travis scott was with
yay at nobu on monday they were later
photographed in the same car heading to
a party at the nice guy where cheney
later joined them also at the nice guy
soiree kim's sister kendall jenner who
attended the celeb-packed event with her
pal haley bieber we really enjoyed it
and while the rapper may be stepping out
with other women according to e.t source
kanye still has hope that he and kim
will get back together it's a sentiment
the rapper expressed live on stage in
december when he changed the lyrics to
his hit run away
[Music]
of course all this comes after yay
publicly slammed his ex on instagram
claiming she didn't provide the address
for their daughter chicago's birthday
party put security on him when he was
playing with his son had him take a drug
test after the party and claimed his
eldest daughter north is on tick tock
against his will
[Music]
following yay's accusations kim
responded with a lengthy notes app
message expressing her desire to resolve
their issues privately i'll voice my
opinion when i think that there's
something that you know has made me done
wrong or even if the messaging's right
maybe it the communication isn't quite
there and now e.t source says kanye has
been lashing out on social media because
he's really hurt
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
he misses his kids and wants what is
best for his family everything he has
been doing has been coming from a place
of feeling deeply hurt and detached from
the people he loves the most in the
world this is his way of fighting to get
his family back
[Music]